[Music]
take a look at this map it shows 23
plants that Ford has in Europe from the
UK to Russia but recently Ford laid out
plans to cut six of these European
factories so six of them they're gonna
sell one they're closing several they're
gonna lay off about 20 percent of their
workforce there
it's about twelve thousand twelve
thousand people but Ford is not the only
US automaker that's scaling back in
Europe two years ago
General Motors pulled out of the market
almost entirely selling their European
brands to French carmaker Pooja
both companies expanded to Europe
decades ago as a wider strategy to scale
globally but they both had trouble
making money in the region let's take a
look at these two charts this one shows
Ford's operating costs in Europe over
the past six years the gray is profits
overall and the reddest profits in
Europe now let's go to GM this chart
shows GM's losses in Europe over the 20
years before they pulled out of the
region so why has it been so hard for
these two automakers to turn a profit in
the European market so the first reason
is that Europe's always been a really
tough market Ford and GM have always
been sort of middle of the pack there I
mean the real powerhouses are Volkswagen
Renault Pujo and when you're sort of a
middling player in Europe where you
already have small profit margins it
just makes life a lot harder for the US
brands GM is making a decision to only
compete in in markets where there were
number one or number two operator and so
they felt like they lost money there for
20 years and they didn't want to
continue to do that and while GM has
largely pulled away from Europe Ford is
looking to scale back and shift focus
what's behind this is a change of
business strategy they're selling fewer
sort of passenger cars to individual
buyers and they're focusing more on the
commercial market where they're strong
which is cargo vans and trucks to
business buyers and governments bigger
vehicles generally equate to bigger
margins there's less competition there
the number one commercial van automaker
there so they already are more crop
in that space and they feel like if they
focus on growing that they can boost
margins even more
the second reason US automakers are
scaling back has to do with Europe's
tight environmental rules another big
factor that GM talked about a lot when
it pulled out was emission standards
Europe has some of the most stringent in
the world and they're only gonna get
tougher and that's gonna cost a lot of
money for the car companies to comply
because they're happy to invest in
hybrids and battery electric cars it's
mostly battery technology the battery
sells the costs have come down some but
most experts think we're still six eight
ten years out from electric car being
sort of parity of cost wise with a gas
powered car
the last major reason is that Ford and
GM are gravitating back to their sweet
spot SUVs and trucks I mean these u.s.
car companies are really good at making
big SUVs and big pickup trucks I mean
Ford's the best-selling truck in the
u.s. is Ford's f-150 it has been for for
years and years GM sells the Chevy
Silverado and the the chevy suburban
these are huge vehicles that aren't sold
in Europe the gas prices are too
expensive you know the streets are
narrower but people don't have as many
big garages like we do in the US and so
I mean that's what Detroit has focused
on that's where they make virtually all
their money and that's why they've never
really been all that great and making
small cars and the European brands have
a big advantage over the US brands there
so they're playing to their strengths
companies like GM and Ford for decades
they tried to build scale not only in
Europe and all around the world because
it's a really capital intensive business
and you need scale and now what you're
seeing is they've got other needs to
spend that capital elsewhere electric
vehicles autonomous vehicle so they
realize it can't be all things to all
people
in all markets and they've got to pick
their battles they've got to choose
where they're gonna spend their money
[Music]